It's our friend, Emmy Eaton!
Emmy!
(audience applauding loudly)
Hi, guys!
I love you, Emmy!
Honestly, being on your show
is like getting the biggest, warmest hug.
It's so nice.
Aww, Emmy!
You know, Emmy,
I'm just so amazed by everything you do.
I just loved your Instagram
'cause you were interviewing Craig Robinson.
You were doing such an amazing job.
You're such an amazing journalist.
Thank you, I saw your comment and I was,
I've been looking forward to being on this.
When we found out, I literally was, like,
jumping up and down, I was so excited, screaming.
I was really happy.
Me, too.
I was so excited to congratulate you
on your beautiful work and be able to say,
"and I'll see you next week," 'cause life with you, Emmy,
is just better, period.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I mean, we've been doing this show together
for two years now, and guess what, Emmy?
We actually made it to Season Three, so-
Yay!
(audience applauding loudly)
I'll be back.
I was gonna say,
and this time, will you come back to New York, please?
Yes.
Okay, perfect.
All right, now back to the news.
Emmy, will you please give us our first headline?
Yes, I will.
This comes from the magazine "The Week".
A woman in Iowa wanted to give her dad a retirement gift
after he retired from the fire department.
She asked fire departments around the country
to send T-shirts.
She wanted one from every state.
She got that, and even more.
She even got one from Afghanistan!
She's going to make them all into a quilt for her dad.
I think I'm gonna ask my fire department to give her one.
Oh, that's a great idea, Emmy.
That's smart, Emmy.
That's a great idea.
It's so special when you get something like that,
a gift that means so much.
You know, after my mom passed away,
her best friend, Bonnie, went into her closet
and took some of her shirts and made me, like,
some pillows with my mom's shirts,
and it's something I treasure so much, you know
because the clothes we wear, they're part of us, you know?
And when you give them and make something else out of them,
it's beautiful, don't you think, Emmy?
Yeah.
Yeah, I do, too.
I think it's so touching and special.
(audience applauding loudly)
All right,
so you're the best in the business, Emmy.
Can I get your take on another story?
Yes.
All right, listen to this.
I love this story.
Netflix has just added
a famous show from Japan,
and it's called "Old Enough".
It's a reality show,
where you get to watch adorable children run errands
all by themselves.
Oh, my gosh!
And anything-
That's cute.
You like that, Emmy?
Yes.
Oh, really?
You wanna run some errands?
(audience laughing)
(chuckling) Yeah.
I got some dry cleaning
you can pick up, okay, Emmy?
Okay.
(audience applauding)
Well, now NPR reports it's not just adorable reality TV.
Parents around the world say they send their kids
on errands early to teach them independence and confidence.
Whether it's getting an egg from the neighbor's house
or running to the market,
kids around the world are getting things done,
just like you, Emmy.
You get it done, right?
Yeah.
What's your favorite kind of errand to run?
I like doing it 'cause at the store,
so, like, the other day, dad let me go up,
we were at a restaurant,
and dad let me go up and order food all by myself.
(Ross gasps)
(audience cheering loudly)
And I got to pay for it, too.
Wow!
(audience applauding)
Emmy, I'm curious.
What do you think about this story,
first of all, as a journalist,
and then what do you think about it as a young woman?
Well, first off, I think that's adorable.
Like, three-year-olds and four-year-olds
are, like, going grocery shopping on their own,
so I think that's adorable.
And as a journalist, I feel like,
like I'd be, actually,
it'd be cool to ask questions to someone who, like,
to one of the kids who have actually done that.
I think that'd be really cool, or one of their parents.
Yeah.
I agree.
It's like, I think there's a richer conversation here
because I think we used to let our kids do
whatever they wanted and no eyes on them,
and now we've kind of become helicopter parents, society,
and so we're all shocked by this story,
but I think there might be a balance we need to get back to
at, like, empowering our kids and letting them, you know,
have autonomy and do things on their own.
And I think we, as parents,
are scared to let our kids do anything,
and that's not good either.
Yeah, but there should be a balance, right,
because as an eight-year-old, I could've run an AT&T store.
I was on top of it, you know what I mean?
I was good, but some kids maybe shouldn't be, you know,
driving to Walmart to pick up groceries.
Well, obviously not before they have a license.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm just eight, I'm not, like, 16.
You can't drive when you're eight here.
Exactly.
That's right, that's right,
but I really like this story,
and I think it's interesting.
I think
we should,
we should find out what our kids are capable of
and support them,
and I'm talking to you, Emmy Eaton,
who is a journalist on the beat
and really doing extraordinary things.
So, look at what people are capable of.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Capable of anything, Emmy.
Thank you.
It's true.
So, I just love this, and I love you, Emmy, so much.
I love you guys, too.
We love you, Emmy!
Season Three, Emmy!
You and me!
Okay, literally,
I'm gonna be on the first episode in person,
and I'm gonna give you guys the biggest hug
in the world.
(Ross laughing loudly)
Well, you can call that a date, Emmy Eaton.
(upbeat music)